okay so how so correct me Drake is is a
part of like some of the locations or is
going to be a part of the locations or
he's not part of location so what
happened is um because I saw the
headline about Drake getting involved
with some Dave's Hot Chicken he has uh
ownership in the entire like in the
entire brand right so Drake owns a piece
of Dave's Hot Chicken a very small piece
of David fried chicken and he's also
like a spokesman for the brand so he'll
help us with like different promotions
that we do um for his birthday we linked
up with him and we gave out like free
sandwiches to everybody that came to the
store how did that happen he's just a
fan he's in La he loves it yeah man he
he loves the chicken and he's a super
dope guy and he's an amazing person and
uh you know after hearing about the
story uh I think he just wanted to kind
of you know be a part of the brand and
help out any way he can so it's been
super cool man and uh Drake calls you
answer
he calls I answer we're gonna be like
how can we get you involved man oh yeah
it's like what up dragon let's get in
trouble no I'm saying if Drake reaches
out it's like he's the biggest [ __ ]
artist you've got to get him involved
yeah like uh it was kind of like surreal
to us to even hear that that was a
possibility right where somebody's like
because you imagine if you're in the
parking lot with 900 and somebody comes
up to you yeah and they're like hey two
or three years from now Drake's gonna
offer to be a part of your company
you're gonna be like all right dude like
order your food and get out you know
what I mean you're not gonna believe
them but you know it's it's wild I mean
look you guys are definitely on your way
to being like the next big franchise 700
locations already in the works yeah I
think they said we're one of the fastest
growing chains in in like U.S America
the food is made well no I mean it's
been five years since we were in a
parking lot yeah and that shit's crazy
yeah I didn't realize that I thought you
guys were at least around like I was
like oh maybe it was like an LA thing
for like 10 years and now it's finally
like the five years dude yeah dude it's
happened overnight yeah it was like an
overnight thing sometimes it's still
surreal to us you know I think the
company why there's like three or four
thousand employees we have and you know
what would be some of the like uh
business side of this that you've kind
of because anytime you scale that fast
yeah you go through like a learning
curve of course you [ __ ] up you adjust
you get it together what are some of the
things that you learned on you know for
anybody who's an up-and-coming business
person or an up and coming restaurant
owner uh what are some of the things
that you kind of had to learn on the fly
or some of the mistakes that you made
that you guys kind of yeah you know you
want to go first you guys can kind of
share it kind of you know because a lot
a lot of people might be watching this
who have a food truck yeah you know who
might want to scale and get a brick and
mortar or yeah
I don't know bro uh I mean I would
definitely say uh partners are very
important you know I think a lot of
entrepreneurs when they start a business
they're afraid to bring in other
partners because there's this fear that
somebody's going to come over and take
over your business and you're going to
lose percentage and things like that uh
I think what we found is
you need to find somebody that you trust
somebody that's experienced in the line
of work you're in and you need to be
able to let people help you grow your
brand right so there was this
interesting thing is like would you
rather have 100 of a grape or you know
50 of a watermelon for sure for sure
right so for me the most important
lesson has been bringing in the right
Partners people you have good chemistry
with people you can grow the company
with people that have the same goals as
you right because you can bring in
partners that have different goals and
that's that's going to mess everything
up so for me the biggest thing is as a
business owner it's okay to bring in
Partners it's okay to partner up with
people that are
big in the line of work you're in that
could help you out yeah I think that
that's something like you said I think
that's some pride [ __ ] I think at times
you know especially in the music
industry people are always like yeah
it's like dude
partnering with the right people if you
can make a billion dollars but you know
it's like it's like most people would
rather make a million dollars and say
they own their everything then make like
500 million that's interesting it's like
dude to me it's like and there's just
like things like oh yeah well they want
to work we do make money but it's like
well that's obvious this is business
people are in business to make money you
know people get in a position to make
money if you're gonna be at that mindset
like yeah people just want to make well
obviously dude but the thing is you want
to make money together right you so you
partner up and you gotta help each other
yeah man it has to be you got to bring
in expertise that like I can't do yeah
yeah I think that franchise model is
like a whole like that's a whole new
world that's like a world that I'm sure
is like yeah man because it's it's I
mean because there's this thing about it
it's like right when you're like you
feel this sense of ownership to the
brand because you're a Founder you
started it right and then a franchisee
is a person that believed in your brand
enough to you know we're doing 10 store
deals minimum by the time they invest in
these 10 stores each store is uh you
know let's say 700 000 build out there
so anybody who wants to start with y'all
they gotta commit to 10. it's about a 10
story commitment yeah wow so they need
to be experienced enough to handle those
10 stores right yeah and by the time
they open those 10 stores they've
invested so much money into your brand
that now they feel a sense of ownership
where they also feel like hey this is my
idea I feel like you guys should do this
so you also have to find again this
balance of
this is not just my brand anymore you
know I have franchisees that have
invested as much time and money as I
have into this place yeah it's their
brand too yeah and I got their own 10
locations yeah and I have to respect
their opinion because they're also
living off of this brand so if I don't
listen to what they have to say and I
just run it however we want and they're
not happy it's not going to keep
expanding right so it's all like this
Balancing Act it's all about like um you
know understanding the people around you
and making sure like everybody can win
who's been outside of Drake obviously
who's who you think is like your guys's
like most famous fan Drake aside because
we know Drake's an owner now but like
who do you guys know is just always just
getting chicken well whether it's
delivered to the studio or an athlete or
we have a lot of uh actually a couple of
our investors are Samuel L Jackson's one
of our investors also so Samuel Jackson
owns a little bit uh also of Dave Fried
Chicken it's Dave's Hot [ __ ] I
do I keep saying he needs to make our
training videos just come over here he's
like I want these [ __ ] tenders
but uh Michael Strahan is another one of
our investors
um
um Maria Shriver wow yeah so there's
like a lot of people and then on the
customer side I mean dude the amount of
people we've seen come to Dave's Hot
Chicken everybody yeah it's I'm just
blown us away dude like Eddie Murphy's
and like people just yeah the create
like people that we grew up idolizing
and we were like dude are they really at
Dave's right now or are they really
posting how does Samuel Jackson get
involved just being a fan uh through
Billet like again we when we brought in
Bill and John they kind of had this
network of people that work with they
could pull from me yeah people that
trusted them because they'd already done
this twice right so for them it was just
easy to reach out and like hey this is
uh we think this is a great concept so
we think you guys should be involved
right and on top of that they see the
brand and a lot and the cool thing about
Dave's is Dana needs to do a lot of
convincing because most people oh yeah
oh yeah I'm in you know yeah so you know
it was really cool for us so